see how cigarette - bro and welcome to
so today I thought we're gonna do
another omegle it's been forever since
the last time and faretta pot is for you
rose after all so I'm looking forward to
do some good old change so basically
what we're gonna do is we're gonna ride
in tres pure to pack and then and we're
gonna do video how do I do that
okay finally oh god I don't want to talk
to random you could get dicks out there
alright here we go
why stop no it's not it for a bit come
on what the [ __ ] well you are awesome
George you are awesome yeah
are you okay there you can make everyone
smile you're even Noddy yeah don't do
anything do you have a hat that's better
thank you I should go can't believe it
hahahaha don't be ah no oh no hey what
what's your dog's name pop booshka
babushka named Edgar
I like your boxes Thanks definitely box
down there I can't hear anything
how's the gun okay pretty pretty happy
now
hello and people Nick Smith like what
the hell don't you know who I am
so what kiss thing ever
ah hey to 3 a.m. cure in all the damn
you crazy go to bed right now no I want
to speak to you I've been searching you
for two hours straight
oh wow oh my gosh what happened how does
it offend you like for real like that's
you hey I'm not a 12 year old girl okay
okay hello looking for the name I don't
I don't know I don't think so it's okay
no way peace lies watch what me now
don't hang out eating my patient sucks
and I see you it's like the best thing
ever that a bird under your shoulder
yeah how's it going why are they doing
for you to follow
hahahahaha LSP hi yes how's it going hi
how's it goes ah I'm good how are you oh
god I'm getting shivers tummy and
everything nice exactly ask me okay
summer know make my every [ __ ] day
right right now I'm like I don't know
how to speak English I know it I'm so
excited I love you and I'm so happy
right now
but it's really funny to meet new people
who are looking for you and Rufus wishes
for to present her to you and one ways
for us to meet you oh my god that's
perfect
I'm sorry I just want to say that I love
you and you're amazing and you're so
beautiful oh my god right right back at
you hi ivy oh oh my god I was I was just
on home people for fun and dunno I love
you and if I'm Russian I love you how do
we awesome videos I'm glad to hear a
thank you so much every always it is so
much baby
yeah I get every hour I heard back from
ERISA oh my god yes I'm so happy I'm
happy too with lobster love you so much
oh you're just a mate
believe it I let me so much now you just
make my days oh my god awesome Oh watch
me I thank you for existing my love now
thanks you thank you very good from this
mango locust all right press that's all
the time I had for today with omegle
it's always really cool to chatted with
some of you bros sorry I can't talk to
more anyway I don't know what else to
say just that stay awesome bros i really
do appreciate all your support if it
wasn't for your brothers I wouldn't even
making video so thank you so much say
awesome
it comes a bro